choosing someone to take over a role
from another actor is never easy
especially when the original actor Drew
prays for their take on a character in
the case of these casting switcheroos
the change was just too drastic for
audiences to endure when director Ridley
Scott signed on to direct The Silence of
the Lamb sequel he did so without his
Clarice Starling in place Anthony
Hopkins had already negotiated a return
to the role of Hannibal Lecter but Jody
Foster didn't share his enthusiasm for
the second chapter in the serial killer
story despite winning an Oscar for the
role in the first film she later told
total film the official reason I didn't
do Hannibal is I was doing another movie
Flora Plum so I get to say in a nice
dignified way that I wasn't available
when that movie was being shot but
Clarice meant so much to Lam's director
Jonathan Demi and I there was no way
that either of us could really trample
on her
really interesting
pressed for time
several big-name actresses were
considered to take her place and the
part ultimately went to Julianne Moore
while both Scott and Hopkins were happy
with the choice audiences weren't as
convinced Moore was inevitably compared
to Foster and couldn't measure up to her
predecessor's screen Savvy nor rekindle
the creepy connection Clarice had shared
with Hopkins in the first film Jody
Foster offered her own diplomatic but
Shady take on the film saying simply I
saw Hannibal I won't comment The Mummy
was a surprise smash for Universal
hosting Global receipts of 415 million
dollars and landing on the top 10
highest grossing films in 1999. it
launched Brendan Fraser's career as a
Hollywood action hero and introduced the
world to a stunning new Leading Lady in
Rachel Vice the pair made a compelling
on-screen couple and reprized the roles
in The Mummy Returns which managed to
bring in a nice haul from the box office
as well but by the time the third film
came around Vice was suffering from some
serious mummy fatigue and stepped aside
Vice was rumored to call the script for
The Mummy 3 crap so the studio into
Maria Bello to fill in for the role
unfortunately for Bello her turn in the
role was criticized for lacking the
charm of the original and the film
failed to recoup its production cost in
the domestic box office
why am I laughing the 90s marked a
moment of resurgence for Disney's
animated film collection with films like
Beauty and the Beast and the Lion King
offering a new generation of children
some cartoon movies to sing along to one
of Disney's most beloved films of the
era was Aladdin an oscar-winning take on
the Arabic folk tale about the street
Thief who sheds his rags and won the
heart of a princess Aladdin was packed
full of great musical numbers but the
main reason it became such a smash was
the input of the late Robin Williams as
the genie it's all part and parcel to
hold Genie Geeks
cause me
anybody living the actor confirmed that
he wouldn't be lending his voice to the
directive video sequel The Return of
Jafar after an alleged row with Disney
over its marketing tactics so the search
for a new Genie began Dan castellanetta
the legendary voice of Homer Simpson was
ultimately chosen to voice the big blue
guy but the Simpson star just couldn't
measure up to Williams frenetic
performance the quality of the animation
didn't help matters but castellaneta
lacked the unpredictability that
Williams brought to the genie
essentially doing a watered-down
impression of his predecessor dope there
are five films based on Tom Clancy's
Jack Ryan books but only one actor has
played the protagonist twice eyebrows
were raised when Alec Baldwin was given
the boot after he successfully debuted
Ryan on screen in The Hunt for Red
October Baldwin later implied that the
studio had gone behind his back and
entered into negotiations with Ford to
take the role of Ryan well that was a
guess but it seemed logical even so
Ford's performance in Patriot Games and
clear and present danger became
definitive for the character eight years
later another actor stepped in to bring
a much younger version of Jack Ryan to
the big screen this time it was Ben
Affleck who stepped in for the sum of
all fears his performance in the role
was met with disdain however in the Jack
Ryan franchise never really recovered
after that despite an attempt to reboot
it with Chris Pine in the lead role more
than a decade later following in the
footsteps of Linda Hamilton as Sarah
Connor in The Terminator franchise was
never going to be easy for any actress
Hamilton gave a performance so layered
and compelling that even the most
talented performers have struggled to do
the character Justice the first to give
it a shot was Lena Headey who was cast
in the role in the short-lived TV series
Terminator the Sarah Connor Chronicles
Fox canceled the show after two seasons
citing its high cost as a reason but
hedy's Game of Thrones colleague Emilia
Clarke was willing to give it another go
on the Silver Screen for Terminator
Genesis the film was a box office dud
and was heavily criticized for using the
old time travel Chestnut to rewrite the
beginning of the Terminator story to
suit the filmmaker's purposes the main
problem wasn't the infuriatingly muddled
timeline though it was the casting as
much as TV lovers might dig Clark's
portrayal of Daenerys Targaryen in Game
of Thrones the film crowd was decidedly
not wowed by her run as Sarah Connor
where her line deliveries packed a lot
less punch than the original
if you want to live pass
National Lampoon's Van Wilder isn't
going to be preserved in the Library of
Congress National film registry anytime
soon yet for all of its failings fans of
a certain age remember this movie fondly
this was a time when frat humor was at
its peak and sitting down to watch a
comedy usually meant turning your brain
off for 90 minutes Van Wilder might not
have been the most cerebral comedy of
all time but Ryan Reynolds still
delivered as the fast talking cool guy
who threw the best parties and was a
softie underneath all those crazy Antics
after the cow pen lead sequel was
destroyed by critics The Producers
decided their next move was a prequel
featuring a younger version of Van
Wilder so they brought in Mean Girls
Jonathan Bennett for Van Wilder freshman
year which was a terrible mistake I have
never seen such a sorry display in all
my life the actor couldn't come close to
the Charisma of his predecessor and
produced a feature-length failed
impression effort as a result Major
League was a surprise Grand Slam for
Paramount Pictures and produced two
increasing terrible sequels and while
Charlie Sheen's Wild Thing came back for
a second round at the mound in Major
League two there is another standout
actor from the first film who refused to
run the bases of this franchise again
Wesley Snipes whose Charming Swagger as
the Speedy bass Thief was a home run in
the first movie had no interest in
returning to the Dugout for the second
movie at the time he was well on his way
to becoming a Hollywood MVP in his own
right thanks to movies like White Men
Can't Jump and Demolition Man so he
pretty much priced himself out of the
second movie with the Cleveland Indians
down a man on their roster the
filmmakers termed a relative newcomer
Omar Epps to sub in as a pinch runner
for the project unfortunately Epps
didn't have a strong background in
comedy and his performance was the
Cinematic equivalent of a foul ball read
some of your reviews man one guy said
Willie Mays Hayes couldn't play dead
just a bit outside
the Prisoner of Azkaban might still be a
favorite among some Harry Potter fans
thanks to the arrival of Sirius Black
and that wild whomping willow but the
fact remains that it's the lowest
grossing movie in the franchise and for
many the subdued enthusiasm seems to
stem from the unfortunate arrival of a
new Hogwarts Headmaster in the film
Richard Harris's take on Albus
Dumbledore in the first two movies had
become definitive for Potter fans so
when the actor died after a battle of
Hodgkin's Disease the filmmakers had to
turn to another actor to step into the
Beloved professor's cloak Michael Gambon
seemed like a fine choice to conjure up
for the franchise but his performance in
his first run as Dumbledore was stunted
by the fact that he never read the books
rather than resuming Harris's
spell-bindingly calm and wise demeanor
Gammon delivered a much more Stern and
aggressive version of the character for
his first few outings
that's one of the oldest students to do
it for you you're absolutely sure yes
Gammon would later summon up the same
sort of chill pill that saved the role
from being ruined for children across
the globe but these moments of
mismatching between the Beloved book
character and the screen interpretation
still cost the movie's many house points
in the eyes of the true Potter Fanatics
Halle Berry taking over Michelle
Pfeiffer's role in Catwoman is perhaps
the most infamous example of recasting
going terribly wrong DC's leather-clad
heroine has appeared in numerous Batman
adaptations over the years but
Pfeiffer's psychotically sexy
performance in Tim Burton's Batman
Returns Remains the cat's meow I don't
know about you Miss Kitty but I feel so
much yummy on the actress initially
intended to reprise the role in the solo
spin-off but after years of development
woes her patience reached its limit and
she decided to concentrate on other
commitments after a rigorous recruiting
process Barry was ultimately chosen to
climb into katsu and what a mess it all
was the film was a complete disaster
bombing hard at the box office while
cleaning up at the razzies Barry took
her worst actress when in good humor and
even turned up to accept her award in
person another error in judgment from
the Batman Universe occurred when
Michael Keaton handed over the keys for
Wayne Manor to Val Kilmer Keaton had
portrayed the role in 1989's Batman and
its sequel Batman Returns but he refused
to reprise the role in a third film
after reading the screenplay when
pressed for details Keaton later said
that the script he was shown sucked and
that it was just awful pointing the
blame for his departure squarely at the
writers Val Kilmer clearly didn't share
Keaton's opinion the tombstone star
accepted the role and went into the film
knowing he'd have to contend with a wide
cast of wacky villains as well as a new
director Jill Schumacher ultimately
shouldered a lot of the blame for the
Badness of Batman Forever though his
leading man didn't Escape criticism what
am I
blind is a bat he was quickly replaced
with George Clooney in Batman and Robin
the good news for Kilmer is that
Clooney's turn as The Dark Knight wasn't
any more love than his own and soon
everyone forgot about Kilmer's turn in
the Batmobile look at it take it off
it's Val kilman
oh you're an actor Roger Moore and Sean
Connery each made seven appearances as
James Bond though many 007 fans will
tell you that Connery is the only Bond a
CBS News poll concluded that 51 of
Americans chose Connery as their
favorite bond with Pierce Brosnan coming
in a distant second George lazinby the
man who replaced Connery in the role for
1969's On Her Majesty's Secret Service
received just one percent of the vote
which tells you everything you need to
know about the gulf between these two
actors while critical opinion toward the
film itself has softened over time
lazenby's performance is still a bone of
contention inevitably compared to those
delivered by Connery in the franchise's
five previous entries the Chicago Reader
said that George lazinbi has so much
Reserve as James Bond that he makes Sean
Connery seem almost frenetic by
comparison reviews in the UK were just
as critical of the leading man's turn as
the British secret service agent with
london-based Outlet time out calling him
a stunning non-entity fronting a film
with no redeeming features
1981's The Clash of the Titans attempted
to give Greek mythology the Star Wars
treatment taking the story of Perseus
and turning it into a sprawling epic
director Desmond Davis went with Harry
Hamlin in the role of Perseus a son of
Zeus who in Legend beheads the Gorgon
Medusa in order to save his beloved
princess Andromeda from a giant Kraken
Hamlin remains active in the industry
though he's still arguably best
remembered for his turn as Perseus the
same cannot be said for Sam Worthington
best known as the star of James
Cameron's budding Avatar franchise
director Louis letterier entrusted the
Australian with the lead role in his
2010 remake though his choice was called
into question when the negative reviews
started to pour in worthington's earned
his share of a claim over the years but
the Titans remake is One release he most
likely wouldn't mind leaving off his
resume quickflix's Simon Morado
questioned how Worthington had ever
managed to become a Hollywood actor
after watching his performance as
Perseus in which he does nothing but
glare his battle speeches are neither
arousing nor particularly intelligible
despite its name 1984's Friday the 13th
part for the Final Chapter was far from
the last installment in this
long-running horror franchise in fact
eight more films have been made since
the so-called Final Chapter though the
one that directly followed it marked a
major drop-off in quality part 4 has
been described as one of the last really
excellent horror romps that focus on
character Dynamic and family Felix
Vasquez of Cinema crazed praised Corey
Feldman for his standout performance as
young Tommy Jarvis Feldman went on to
make a name for himself in The Goonies
Stand By Me and the lost boys though
before he did he reprized his Friday the
13th role in 1985's part 5 A New
Beginning unfortunately he only appeared
in the prologue and a time Jump meant he
was replaced by the painfully dull John
Shepard teenage Tommy was static
compared to his younger self though
Shepard shouldn't shoulder the blame
entirely some blamed what they called
the hamfested directing of David
Steinman while James Kendrick of Q
Network argued that the Gory antics are
so restrained by the insistence of the
MPAA rating system that the film feels
like it was edited with one of Jason's
bloody Rusty weapons
veteran film critic Mark kermode summed
up 2015's the transporter refueled with
a single question what exactly is the
point of a transporter movie without
Jason Statham when it was revealed that
Ed scrin was to replace Statham as
special forces opt-turned private driver
Frank Martin in the fourth transporter
film questions were raised about the
former's ability to carry the franchise
forward though the transporter films
didn't exactly change the action movie
landscape they benefited from Statham's
presence athletic prowess and combat
skills his replacement lacked that
experience and it showed scrin began
taking classes in various martial arts
disciplines as he prepared for both the
transporter refueled and his role as
Ajax in Deadpool but even he
acknowledged that he was way behind many
of his peers in that department he told
the BBC I'm very respectful and realize
I'm not going to be able to do things
meant for 10 or 20 years of training the
action in The Transporter refueled was
ultimately limited by the nustar's
fledgling abilities Ed scrin's one and
only outing as Frank Martin was a
commercial and critical flop that left
the Luke Besson produced franchise dead
in the water
Rooney Mara took the role of androgynous
computer hacker Lizbeth Salander
starring opposite Daniel Craig in 2011's
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo when the
2018 sequel the girl in the spider's web
was announced fans of David Fincher's
critically acclaimed first film were a
little disappointed that both Mara and
Craig had been recast and so was Mira
she told Yahoo I was hopeful to come
back but they decided to do a different
thing it was always a character I wanted
to revisit but that's not what happened
severe goodness and replaced Daniel
Craig while Claire Foy stepped into the
pale pierced skin of Salander
unfortunately she didn't look
comfortable in it at the time she was
receiving a claim for her turn as the
young Queen Elizabeth II in the crown
but Foy couldn't pull off salander's
cold eccentricities with the same Poise
as her predecessor critics were by and
large unimpressed with her version of
The Goth hacker with many questioning
why she was chosen for the part The
Observers Wendy Ides said much as I
admire her Foy is miscast here she's
just too empathetic for a role that
requires an almost reptilian lack of
emotion Indie wire's senior film critic
David Ehrlich called her both terrible
and terribly miscast
the first RoboCop Stars Peter Weller as
the titular cyborg he roams a dystopian
crime-written version of Detroit
mercilessly dealing with lawbreakers
well it reprized the role in RoboCop 2
but turned down the chance to play him
again in a third movie Producers needed
a replacement and their hearts were
apparently set on a little-known actor
named Robert John Burke in a 2015
interview Burke said in God's Great
Earth they thought I was the only actor
who could do it I don't know why I think
physically I poked like Peter Weller and
I had also had extensive karate training
pantomime training and body training and
I fit the suit unsurprisingly handing
the lead role over to the relatively
inexperienced perk just because he kind
of resembled Weller didn't work out very
well he may have looked like him in the
suit but as the New York Times said in
its review of the box office bomb Burke
is lacking his forerunner's
tongue-in-cheek glint of authoritarian
machismo you have the right to an
attorney
from his delivery to the way he moved
Burke just wasn't as convincing as
RoboCop as Empire noted he appeared to
be a lot less comfortable with the
hardware
1988's big is often cited as Tom Hanks
breakout movie but he actually announced
himself as a potential star some four
years earlier in Ron Howard's fantasy
rom-comp Splash Hanks plays Alan Bauer a
young man who returns to the spot of
what he believes was a near-death
hallucination to discover that the woman
he saw in the water the day he almost
drowned is indeed real Allen Falls for
Mermaid Madison and ditches his life on
land to live under the sea with her in a
goofy yet undeniably feel-good ending
it's a Beloved movie though the same
cannot be said about the Obscure made
for TV sequel Splash 2 helmed by writer
director and actor Greg ontonachi the
highly forgettable and completely
unnecessary Splash 2 brought Alan and
Madison back to dry land totally
ignoring the fact that the government
wanted to lock her up in a lab in the
previous installment Todd Waring took
over as Alan Bauer but despite his best
efforts he lacked the Everyman charm and
comedic timing that was abundant in
Hanks filmfad said in its review of the
sequel the less said about the actors
were played facing Tom Hanks and John
Candy the better
Alice had its fair share of character
Replacements during its run from 1978 to
1991 as any show that airs for 14
Seasons inevitably does but one that
still stands out with fans to this day
is the role of Miss Ellie Ewing Barbara
Bell Gettys originated the part and
played it right up until 1984. when she
left in order to have a quadruple bypass
heart surgery at the time she was
replaced by Donna Reed and fans were not
into it in fact fans were so not into it
that six months later when Belle Gettys
had recovered she was asked back onto
the show Reid didn't go down without a
fight though she tried to Sue and halt
production in the end the judge didn't
agree with her in the series carried on
Belle Gettys continued playing Miss
Ewing for the remainder of the series
bringing life to the character for over
300 episodes
when suits hit Airwaves in 2011 critics
had positive but somewhat mixed reviews
on the premise which turned the tired
legal drama format on its head with the
introduction of Mike Ross a wannabe
lawyer without a degree and Harvey
Specter the Hotshot attorney who
mentored him shot in Toronto the series
wound up being a massive hit for the
network and was considered the last of
its blue skies era hey are you ready for
this
I am however that all ended in 2017 when
Patrick J Adams and Meghan Markle who
played Mike Ross in his love interest
Rachel Zane respectively announced they
were leaving the show after seven
seasons at that point another original
series star Gina Torres also exited
leaving the cast down three members as a
result the show brought on dulay hill
and Catherine Heigl while upping Amanda
Scholl from recurring to full-time
status in season 8. however the new mix
of characters didn't resonate as well as
the old school ones and the Show wrapped
for good in season 9.
it seems like networks have been trying
to recreate the Soapy Prime Time success
of Desperate Housewives ever since that
show went off the air in 2012. ABC
thought it came close with the 2013
entry Mistresses which failed to earn
critical praise but still snagged a
second season renewal following its
steeny first season summer run fans
continued to bake in the hotness of it
all the following summer but when the
show was renewed for a third season ABC
revealed it was moving production from
Los Angeles to Vancouver that was bad
news for Star Alyssa Milano who couldn't
be that far from her family Milano
stepped away as a result and the show
recruited Jennifer Esposito to fill that
void with her Calista Reigns character
that lasted one season and then Esposito
also left the series in order to pursue
other projects surprisingly the show was
renewed for one more season but without
Milano fans just didn't seem that into
it and the series was axed for good
after a very dramatic season 4 finale
it's no secret that Julie Benz did not
want to exit Dexter after she was killed
off in the show's fourth season she
admitted to reporters that she quote
bald and said it was the worst thing to
ever happen to her in her career it
seems as though fans felt the same way
while the decision was purely a creative
one the salt in the wound for passionate
viewers came in season 5 when Julia
Stiles was cast as Lumen Pierce a new
love interest for Dexter the character
lasted the entire season and finally
exited ahead of season six for many it
was a turning point especially as they
watched the show go on to cast other
guest stars like Colin Hanks and Yvonne
strahovsky to fill the void then writers
eventually went so far as to almost pair
Dexter up with his adoptive sister Deb
chemistry is particularly important when
casting a family sitcom so fans were a
little concerned when Julia Butters left
American housewife as the youngest Auto
child ahead of its Fifth Season Premiere
Butters brought a notable charm to the
character of an a cat Auto so much so
that when Quentin Tarantino saw her on
his screen he cast her as serious young
actress Trudy in Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood that gig wound up being a game
changer for the young actor because all
kinds of subsequent offers came in and
she left the ABC series to pursue them
in turn American housewife snatched up
Giselle Eisenberg fresh from her Four
Season run on the CBS sitcom Life In
Pieces while Eisenberg is undeniably
talented it's been hard for fans to
adapt to the change following the show's
return in 2020.
yeah kids change it's no secret that the
children on Tim Allen's Last Man
Standing changed pretty drastically over
the show's run Amanda Fuller joined the
project in season two as Kristen Baxter
replacing Alexandra crosney who
originated the role then there's the
fact that four different actors have
played the part of Kristen's son Boyd as
the character has aged over the years
but it was Molly ephraim's exit from the
series Following season six that really
threw Last Man Standing fans for a loop
as middle child Mandy Ephraim had her
share of meaty storylines that made her
a show fixture but when ABC canceled
last man standing in 2017 inbox revived
it for a seventh season run Ephraim
didn't go with it she had signed up for
new projects and was unable to return
Molly McCook was cast in her place and
although the series lasted three seasons
on Fox before its cancellation in 2021
the character was just never the same
now this is a story all about how the
casting on Fresh Prince got turned
upside down fans everywhere are familiar
with the behind the scenes Strife that
went down between Will Smith an original
Aunt Viv actress Janet Hubert who played
the role for three notable Seasons
before refusing to renew her contract
under what she considered to be a bad
deal as a result she exited the show and
she was replaced by Daphne Maxwell Reed
an actor who was originally considered
for the role but refused to audition
because a TV show starring a young
rapper didn't sound like her thing there
are a lot of sick demented perverts out
there
greetings are
although The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air
went on for three more seasons with the
new on Viv there was no replacing
Hubert's comedic timing later when Smith
got the gang back together for the 2020
reunion he and Hubert sat down for the
first time to finally iron things out
the result was the two on fives meeting
for the very first time as many fans
wondered but the show could have been
had Hubert stayed on after all
when the sixth season of this comedy
kicked off in 1969 viewers were left
twitching harder than Samantha in her
magical nose when Emmy nominee Dick York
was suddenly gone as Darren Stevens in
his place was Dick's Sargent and fan
speculation as to what happened kicked
into overdrive as it turned out York had
previously entered his back pretty badly
while shooting a movie and the pain led
him down a dark path of prescription
pills eventually he realized he had to
leave the show and his career never
really recovered as for sergeant he
stayed in the role until the series
finale in 1972. many fans felt the
series wasn't the same though and it's
worth noting that although Sergeant won
a most Irreplaceable replacement TV Land
award in 2006 he was never nominated for
an Emmy Award like his predecessor
have you heard the one about the two
beckies when Roseanne kicked off its
first iteration back in 1988 it was
actor Lisi Goranson who originated the
role of Becky the eldest child to Dan
and Roseanne fast forward to season five
though and gorinson had enrolled in
college and as a result she was only
available to film part-time usually for
a phone conversation the following year
producers wanted Becky back in a more
permanent role so they recast her with
Sarah chalk that was fine but things got
complicated when Goranson briefly
returned in season 8 after finishing
school the following year chalk was back
in the role and the two Becky's became a
running thing that frustrated some
viewers to their relief both actors were
asked back for the Roseanne Revival in
2018 but only gorenson returned to play
Becky producers hired chalk to instead
play a character named Andrea who asked
Becky to be her surrogate in a clever
wink to the whole situation
for five and a half Seasons Nashville
fans followed Connie Britton's Superstar
character Rayna James as she balanced
motherhood singing and reconnecting with
her one true love Deacon Claiborne but
that all Came Crashing Down When
Burton's shocked fans and exited the
series in 2017 with a devastating
storyline that left her family all alone
it turned out Britain was ready for a
change but she was having a hard time of
letting go of the people she worked with
so when seemed he revived Nashville for
a fifth season after ABC ax did at the
end of its run in 2016. Britain decided
it was finally time to move on after the
fictional singer's death there were
plenty of other characters to root for
and the show may have ultimately
survived but then the writers introduced
Caitlyn Doubleday as Jessie Kane a new
love interest for Deacon and loyal fans
were definitely not happy the series
took a bit of a dive in season six
ultimately wound up being the last
throughout its eight season run house
had a history of replacing characters to
switch up the storyline and keep things
fresh but season 7 is when the casting
situation really got out of control that
year Olivia Wilde took a leave of
absence from her fan favorite gig as 13.
to film Cowboys and Aliens while
original actor Lisa Edelstein announced
her departure as Dr Lisa Cuddy
considering the shake-ups it seemed
pretty clear to longtime fans that the
series was nearing its expiration date
to try and inject new life into the show
producers hired Odette annable and
Charlene Yee to play the latest fellows
alongside Amber tamblin but the new crew
never quite lived up to the original
cast and as season 8 was in progress Fox
announced that it would also be the
show's last
today Beverly Hills 90210 is also known
as TV's most famous zip code but before
the show earned that status its original
cast had to win over Prime Time fans
with its older actors in soapy
storylines enter Jason Priestley and
Shannon Doherty as the famous Walsh
twins Brandon and Brenda from the start
fans were into their chemistry with the
show's other original cast members but
behind the scenes it was a different
story reports of onset tension between
Doherty and the rest of the cast
specifically Jenny Garth surfaced and in
1994 Doherty was axed from the show for
good that year she was replaced by
Tiffany Thiessen who had her own fan
base from her days as Kelly on Saved by
the Bell but not all fans were into the
new character Valerie Malone a family
friend of the walshes it was clear Val
was meant to replace Brenda but Saved by
the Bell fans weren't sure how to
receive this new adult version of the
actor meanwhile the character had her
moments but she was no Brenda and the
tone of the series changed with her
Casting she stayed on for most of the
rest of the series but to this day you
can ask any 90210 fan which character
they relate to most and you probably
won't find many Valerie stands out there
Steve Carell was a well-known comic
force from The Daily Show and Anchorman
before he got his biggest break with the
small screen comedy series The Office
the show was an American adaptation of
the Ricky Gervais BBC sitcom with the
same name and became wildly popular with
audiences corel's film career started to
take off shortly thereafter with
starring roles in movies like the 40
year old virgin Little Miss Sunshine and
Crazy Stupid Love elevating him to
household name status so in 2013 when
corel's contract with the office was up
he opted to walk away from the series
even though it was still a critical and
ratings hit for NBC The Awkward lovelorn
Michael Scott Finally Found Love with HR
Director Holly and they moved away to
Colorado but Dunder Mifflin still needed
a boss and that came in the form of oily
unsettling Robert California CEO of its
parent company saber wow
I will not be blackmailed by some
ineffectual privileged defeat soft
debutante and it was all downhill from
there the show's critical favor and
viewership numbers took a nosedive and
the series finally came to a close after
two Corel free seasons for its first six
seasons The X-Files was a huge hit for
Fox and made its on-screen pair of
paranormal investigators International
stars but prior to the start of the
series seventh season David Duchovny
sued the network claiming that it had
sold rights to reruns of the show at a
discount to its own Affiliates and
cheated the stars out of profits while
the lawsuit was eventually settled it
was filed right when dakovny was
negotiating working on future seasons of
the show and neither he nor Fox were
Keen to continue working together so a
deal was reached dakovney's character
Fox Mulder would mysteriously disappear
at the end of season 7 and would only
appear in a handful of episodes in
season 8 but Jillian Anderson's Agent
Scully still needed someone to work with
in his absence so producers had Edition
dozens of actors and eventually settled
on Robert Patrick to come in as FBI
agent John Doggins another actress was
also hired in case Anderson decided to
leave the show after her contract into
two it didn't matter much though because
without the company in his regular role
viewers tuned out she saved me
as difficult and as frustrating as it's
been sometimes damn strict rationalism
and science has saved me a thousand
times over
this ABC sitcom was forced to reformat
after the Unexpected death of its star
eight simple rules was built around TV
Legend John Ritter who starred as a
cranky Suburban dad desperately trying
to rein in his wild teenage children
filming had just begun on the second
season of the series when Ritter fell
ill on the set and sought medical
treatment he died later that day of a
heart defect that had never been
diagnosed ABC announced that the show
would go on and it did with some
necessary changes no longer a show about
a cranky dad it became one about a
family trying to pick up the pieces
after the death of its patriarch two new
stars joined the cast to fill the void
left by Ritter cousin CJ and Grandpa Jim
but without Ritter the show only lasted
another season before being shelved for
good actor musician Steve Burns beat out
roughly 1 000 other actors in 1996 for
the only human role on Blues Clues
Nickelodeon's interactive animation
live-action hybrid show for preschoolers
Burns played the strike shirted the host
and owner of the cartoon dog named Blue
he talked directly to the young viewers
at home urging them to help solve each
episode's riddle or Mystery by yelling
things at their screens in 2002 after
about 100 episodes Burns decided it was
time to leave the series he wanted to
take on other roles as well as perform
music Nickelodeon hired actor Donovan
Patton to be the new host of Blues Clues
playing Steve's younger brother Joe so
is not to traumatize or confuse the
show's very young viewers Steve
carefully explained that he was leaving
for college and Joe would be looking
after blue Patton as Joe proved to be
the gentle and affable host Blues Clues
needed but he just couldn't replace
someone so closely associated with roll
to an army of toddlers after around 50
episodes with Pat and his Joe Blue's
Clues was canceled this comedy about
medical interns desperately trying to
figure out what they were doing as they
worked in a hospital was a critically
acclaimed emmy-nominated hit over its
first few seasons on NBC the Network
dropped the show after seven seasons
only to see ABC pick it up the show's
writers and cast prepared a true series
finale at the end of the year only for
ABC to unexpectedly renew the series
again for season nine but starred Zach
Braff the focus of the show as young Dr
John Dorian was ready to move on to
other things
onward
oh good God so the show was retooled and
rebooted no longer taking place at a
teaching hospital but at a medical
school Dr Cox and Dr Turk were now
teachers instead of active surgeons
I'm just back to teach some classes
replacing braf as the center of the show
and narrator was Dr Lucy Bennett but the
big changes were too much to take and
the ninth season of Scrubs was also its
last Michael J fox returned to regular
series television for the first time
since the end of family ties with Spin
City on the ABC sitcom he played Mike
Flaherty a Wheeler Dealer for a New York
City Deputy Mayor two years later Fox
announced that he had been battling
Parkinson's disease and left the show to
spend more time raising funds for
research on the disease replacing him as
Deputy Mayer was a guy named Charlie
Crawford portrayed by Charlie Sheen with
fox out the show became more of a
romantic comedy surrounding Sheen and
Heather Locklear's characters but
viewership tank shortly after the
replacement so ABC cut the cord on Spin
City
okay I guess you guys aren't ready for
that yet
but your kids are gonna love it
Delta Burke had not been happy on the
set of Designing Women for years she
even claimed that a producer routinely
screamed to cast members and told them
They Were Expendable and criticized
Burke when she gained weight are you
serious CBS grew so tired of Burke
publicly trashing the show's producers
and the network in the press that they
fired her from the show and co-star Gene
Smart followed her out the door shortly
thereafter
remember every time I look over the sofa
I kind of miss seeing her that meant
that Designing Women had lost half its
main cast but the show was still a
ratings draw so the network brought in
some Replacements now I know that all of
our nerves are a little bit jangly
because of the silly old money situation
but you know what we got to do
we got to look for the light Julia Duffy
arrived as Suzanne's cousin and Jan
Hooks came in as Carlene Charlene's
sister despite ratings on par with
previous years CBS fired Duffy after her
soul season on the series and replaced
her with Judith Ivy as a rich Texan
Widow named Vijay Poteet it didn't do
much good because CBS moved the show to
Friday nights where it slipped into
ratings Oblivion and then cancellation
and that is The Night the Lights Went
Out in Georgia after seven seasons of
riding on a high ratings wise at least
two of that 70 shows main stars decided
to step away from the series Topher
Grace decided to leave the show in order
to more fiercely pursue his blossoming
film career and was written out of the
eighth season altogether meanwhile
Ashton Kutcher decided his time in the
bell bottoms was done too but did appear
for a few of season 8's early episodes
to replace two very big holes in the
cast producers hired Mad TV veteran Josh
Myers his character Randy joins Hyde's
record store grooves and has a brief
relationship with Donna but Randy didn't
have much time to mesh with the Ensemble
because the decimated cast led to
diminished popularity for the show and
it was ultimately canned at the end of
the season you have the right to remain
even though Community never had a huge
audience during its five-year run on NBC
it was still a critically acclaimed
comedy with a passionate cult following
five seasons was ultimately NBC's limit
but internet giant Yahoo stepped in and
renewed Community for a sixth season
intending to position the comedy as a
premier offering on its streaming
service Yahoo screen original regulars
Joe McHale Jillian Jacobs Danny booty
Ken John and Allison Bree followed the
series to Yahoo but the show had already
been losing cast members left and right
and kept losing them as it transitioned
to streaming Chevy Chase Donald Glover
and Yvette Nicole Brown were not part of
the regular cast of communities sixth
season new actors were added including
Keith David and Paget Brewster but it
just didn't work out and there was no
seventh season of Community on Yahoo
screen or anywhere not enough people
tuned in and the show didn't generate as
much advertising Revenue as Yahoo had
hoped the revenue was so small that it
effectively led to the complete shutdown
of Yahoo screen and show may be canceled
and moved to the internet where it turns
out tens of millions were watching the
whole time may not matter if a
commercial man with disclaimer gag which
may descend into vain Chuck Glory S
Grant by narcissistic Creator Sleepy
Hollow [__] her Supernatural police
drama was always a little bit different
than other cop shows for starters one of
his main characters was Ichabod Crane
from Washington Irving's short story The
Legend of Sleepy Hollow who comes back
to life in the present day after having
died 200 years or so prior crane then
helps fight Supernatural menaces
alongside police Lieutenant Abby Mills
over three seasons a Sleepy Hollow
settled into its role as a quirky police
procedural and then it did the
unthinkable Abby died and actress Nicole
Bahari left the series despite her steep
loss of viewers from season 1 to season
3 Sleepy Hollow returned for a fourth
season without hubby ichibald was now
partnered with the homeland security
agent named Diana Thomas the cast
reboots didn't do Sleepy Hollow any
favors though the show fell even further
in the ratings and was soon canceled
step by step was an ABC sitcom about
Carol and Frank Lambert two single
parents who bring their families
together in addition to all their kids
Frank's nephew Cody lived in a van
outside the house Cody was a
good-natured air-headed California dude
basically a sitcom version of Ted from
Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure
affable and enthusiastic acting by Sasha
Mitchell made the character a fun
favorite but in 1995 when Mitchell was
arrested for spousal assaults he was
convicted later that year and sentenced
to three years of Probation and spousal
abuse counseling Mitchell wound up
behind bars for violating his parole and
reportedly attacked his wife again at
the beginning of the sixth season of
Step by Step Cody was gone replaced by
Jean-Luc a heavily accented hairdresser
colleague of carols playing Jean-Luc as
Bronson Pinchot best known for playing
the excitable heavily accented bulky on
perfect strangers and the excitable
heavily accented surge in Beverly Hills
Cop the newcast Edition didn't work and
ABC canceled step by step at the end of
the season the show then moved to CBS
for a final year without Pinto
after the first season of The Facts of
Life the number of main characters was
cut from 10 to just 5. Eastland boarding
school house mother Mrs Garris and four
female students after those four
graduated in the fourth season Mrs
Garrett opened a gourmet shop and hired
her former students and after season 7
Mrs Garrett herself Charlotte Ray left
the show she thought it was time to move
on later telling Entertainment Weekly
that the show could continue on without
her but producers love the show's
Dynamic of a wise older woman Doling out
advice to young women so they created
the role of Mrs Garrett's sister Beverly
Ann however the replacement didn't quite
work and by the ninth season The Facts
of Life was unceremoniously canceled
American Idol has created a number of
stars such as Kelly Clarkson Jennifer
Hudson Adam Lambert and of course Simon
Cowell audiences couldn't get enough of
the judge who was often brutally and
hilariously honest with contestants okay
best singer in America oh yeah right I
can honestly say you want the worst
singer in America Cowell was the biggest
star of the series which was the most
watched show on TV for an impressed and
did eight straight Seasons but in 2010
after nine Seasons he moved on in part
to develop the American version of his
British talent series The X Factor Idol
producers had a hard time replacing
Cowell as well as fellow original judge
Paula Abdul the idol judge's table saw a
lot of stars take a stab at it with
actual singers just couldn't fill the
void left by the music industry guy who
criticized the singers maybe we've made
a mistake we made a big Miss r
news radio NBC's critically acclaimed
but low-watched comedy had no plans to
replace one of its characters and a
best-known star but tragedy forced to
producer's hand between the show's
fourth and fifth season star Phil
hartsman was shot to death by his
troubled wife it was a horrific crime
and a devastating loss for the show but
in order to complete enough episodes to
sell the show in the syndication news
radio was picked up for another season
anyway in the season premiere it was
explained that Hartman's character
pompous radio news reader Bill McNeil
died of a sudden heart attack replacing
him at the news reader's desk was a new
character Max Lewis weird insecure and
holy and qualified for the position Max
was portrayed by Hartman's friends and
Saturday Night Live co-star John Lovitz
while love it to the great comic actor
he just couldn't overcome the sadness
looming over news radio Lovett's first
season would be the show's last
for the Fox television adaptation of
Lethal Weapon claim Crawford took over
for Mel Gibson as Loose Cannon Martin
Riggs and if onset reports published by
variety at any indication Crawford was
even harder to control than his
character in an episode he directed a
special effects explosion went to Rye
sending a piece of debris at co-star
Damon Wayans when Wayans complained
Crawford referred to as co-star as a
crybaby another time he reportedly
screamed and swore at a group of
children who wandered near on yet
another occasion he reportedly proved so
hard to work with that a director walked
off the set in the middle of a shoot in
May 2018 after two seasons producers
eliminated what they thought was the
root cause of the show's problems and
fired Crawford they rushed to find
somebody to replace him and quickly
hired Sean William Scots to play Wesley
Cole a new partner for detective Roger
murtar Scott couldn't save the show
however all that tension didn't totally
dissipate with weigh-ins announcing that
he planned to leave this series in the
middle of the Season Fox decided to wash
their hands of the whole thing in May
2019 and canceled Lethal Weapon from
1998 to 2007 Kevin James and Leah Remini
starred on the popular CBS sitcom King
of Queens James would go on to star in a
string of movies like grown-ups and Paul
Blart Mall Cop but in 2016 he returned
to the weekly CBS sitcom grind with
Kevin can wait James portrayed Kevin
Gable a family man who hassled the labor
tiring from his police job due to family
and money issues playing opposite James
was Erin Hayes as Kevin's wife Donna
Gable at least that's how it was for the
first season Kevin can wait producers
for a van the show for season two they
killed off Donna Gable and fired Hayes
James explained the decision to the New
York daily news by saying we were
literally just running out of ideas they
also brought in a new face who was
really a familiar face surprisingly Leah
Remini joined Kevin can wait as Kevin's
business partner Vanessa however the
nostalgic rebooting couldn't overcome
the weird behind-the-scenes Shaker and
ratings actually dropped in season two
after the conclusion of the sitcom
second ill-fated season CBS didn't wait
to cancel Kevin
an ensemble drama with a culturally
diverse cast set in an often surreal
rural Alaska Northern Exposure was
radically different from most other
shows on television Rob Morrow starred
as Dr Joel Fleischman a snobby New York
City Doctor Who heads North to service a
Tiny Town of Sicily Northern Exposure
was a big hit reaching the top 20 in the
ratings and earning four straight Emmy
nominations for Outstanding Drama Series
and winning the prize in 1992. but
fleischmann's desire to leave Alaska
never faded Amaro wanted to bounce too
halfway through the show's sixth season
Morrow fled Northern Exposure reportedly
to pursue new acting challenges and a
movie career replacing him was a new
Precision Dr Philip Capra portrayed by
Paul provenza a respected stand-up
comedian who had little acting
experience apart from his work on
sitcoms Latin experience seems to have
showed after just half a season with
provenza at the helm the network
canceled Northern Exposure
the high school sitcom Head of the Class
debuted on ABC in 1986 it explored the
relationships between a diverse group of
Highly Advanced Manhattan students and
the history teacher Charlie Moore played
by Howard Hessman a big part of
Whitehead of the class worked is that it
was Ensemble focused the various kids
had personal and academic problems and
Mr Moore helped them sort things out
Hessman portrayed more with
understatements and subtlety letting his
younger co-stars take Center Stage
however the actor hated Head of the
Class in 1989 he told a reporter that he
thought the show didn't have much work
he said we're not doing the show that I
was led to believe or do and it's
difficult for me to get off that
unsurprisingly Hessman left the show in
1990 in his plays for Scottish comedian
Billy Connolly as a teacher named Billy
McGregor all of a sudden a show about
high school kids problems was a show
about wacky Mr McGregor ABC seemed to
realize that too in 1991 the network
canceled Head of the Class and quickly
ordered up a new show called Billy
Connolly continued to play McGregor who
was now living as a border and a
California single mother's house
[Music]